usa los símbolos de menor que mayor que
o igual para comparar las fracciones 21
entre 28 y lo voy a poner con nuestro
color 21 entre 28 y 6 entre 9 y también
voy a comparar seis números ok tengo
estas atracciones y quiero compararlas
ahora se me ocurren varios
procedimientos para encontrar la forma
de resolver este problema pero creo que
la forma más intuitiva y en la que más
vamos a emprender es compararlos con un
denominador común para entender bajo
este en un nudo común cuál de estas dos
fracciones es más grande que la otra o
si son iguales así que tras lo que voy
es tras un denominador común sin embargo
21 entre 28 y 6 entre nueve son
fracciones que todavía se pueden reducir
por lo tanto qué te parece si trabajamos
con la primera fracción 21 entre 28 para
reducirla un poco y encontrar una
fracción equivalente más simplificada
que esta que tengo aquí si encuentro una
fracción equivalente más pequeña me va a
ser mucho más fácil trabajarla
así que qué te parece si a esto lo
dividimos tanto arriba como abajo el 37
y como voy a hacer lo mismo tanto arriba
como abajo entonces recuerda que la
fracción se va a mantener intacta 21
entre 7 es 3 y 28 en 37 es 4 es decir
que 21 entre 28 es lo mismo que tres
cuartos y lo voy a poner aquí abajo esto
es exactamente lo mismo que tres cuartos
ahora fíjate que seis novenos tiene el
mismo problema
69 nos lo podemos certificar un poco más
6 entre 9 aunque te parece si yo divido
tanto arriba como abajo entre 3 entre 3
y también voy a dividir esta parte de
abajo entre 3 como estoy haciendo lo
mismo arriba como abajo la fracción se
conserva y aquí me va a quedar en 6
entre 32 y 9 entre 3 y 3 por lo tanto
estoy diciendo que 6 novenos es lo mismo
que dos tercios esto es lo mismo que dos
tercios es decir esencialmente tengo que
comparar tres cuartos
tercios y esto está mucho más fácil de
compararlo que 21 entre 28 y 6 novenos
porque encontrar un denominador común
entre estos dos me saldrá un número
gigante igual y al final del vídeo lo
hacemos contando ahora si yo tengo que
21 entre 28 es lo mismo que tres cuartos
y 6 novenos es lo mismo que dos tercios
como puedo encontrar un denominador
común entre estos dos tengo 4 y 3 pues
recuerda que el denominador común
siempre es el mínimo común múltiplo
entre los dos denominadores en este caso
entre el 4 y el 3 pero el medio común
múltiplo entre el 4 y el 3 es la
multiplicación de ambos porque el 3 es
un número primo y el 4 solamente se
puede descomponer en 2 por 2 el 4 es lo
mismo que 2 por 2 y darte cuenta que dos
no es factor de 3 por lo tanto el mínimo
múltiplo de 4 y 3 es a la multiplicación
de los dos que es 12 es decir que voy a
escribir a esta fracción iv a esta
fracción con denominador 2 con
denominador 12 y con denominador 12 ok
con esto voy a lograr que los dos tengan
el mismo denominador y ahora si los voy
a poder comparar y ver cuál es más
grande ahora date cuenta que tres
cuartos cuando yo tengo el denominador
cuatro para llegar a ser denominador 12
lo que hice fue multiplicarlo por 3 de
aquí para acá lo que hice fue
multiplicar por 3 pues como estoy
multiplicando por tres la parte de abajo
también tengo que multiplicar por tres
la parte de arriba para obtener el
numerador entonces voy a multiplicar por
3 3 y 3 por 3 le va a dar 9 es decir que
tres cuartos
es lo mismo que 9 12 a 2 ahora vamos a
fijarnos en la refracción en la fracción
de los textos el denominador es 3 y para
llegar a hacer ahora un denominador con
12 lo que hice fue multiplicar por 4 lo
que hice fue multiplicar por 4
es la parte de arriba para que se
mantenga igual la fracción tengo que
multiplicará por cuatro la tengo que
multiplicar por cuatro para obtener el
numerador de esta fracción 2 por 4 es
porque es decir que dos tercios es
exactamente lo mismo que 8 sobre 12 y
que crece aquí ya tengo dos fracciones
que tienen el mismo denominador el
denominador es el 12 1 912 ambos y la
otra es 8 12 años y recuerda 9 12 ambos
es lo mismo que tres cuartos que es lo
mismo que 21 entre 28 y 8 12 ambos es lo
mismo que dos tercios que es lo mismo
que 6 entre 9 ya ver si ya que tengo el
denominador común aquí tengo 9 partes de
12 y aquí tengo 8 partes de 12 por lo
tanto ya se nota con mucha claridad que
el que gana es este éste es más grande
que éste debido a que aquí tengo un 12
hago más que aquí y entonces estoy
diciendo que 9 doceavos es más grande
que 8 12 ambos y aquí te los puedo
comparar estoy diciendo que tres cuartos
es más grande que dos tercios
ya que ya los puedo comparar estoy
diciendo que 21 328 es más grande que 6
entre el 9 ya utilice esta rotación y
entonces ya tengo la respuesta de este
problema ahora vámonos con calma aunque
ya tengo la respuesta de este problema
fíjate que utilizamos simplificar las
fracciones para llegar a la respuesta de
una manera mucho más sencilla ahora qué
te parece si empezamos el principio
comparando 21 entre 28 y a 6 entre 9
pero no simplificamos las fracciones
vamos en el mismo método vamos a buscar
un denominador común pero en esta
ocasión no voy a simplificar las
fracciones por lo tanto tras lo que voy
en un inicio es buscar el mínimo común
múltiplo el mínimo común múltiplo entre
28 y 9 y para esto déjame descomponer al
28109 de factores primos así que lo voy
a hacer por acá el 28 y tiene mitad la
mitad de 28 es 14 14 tiene mitad la
mitad de 14 es 7 y tanto 2 y 7 son
los primos y 99 tienen tercera y la
tercera de 9 estrés por lo tanto el
mínimo común múltiplo entre 28 y 9 es 2
por 2 por 7 por 3 por 3 es decir que 28
9 no tienen factores en común y por lo
tanto el mínimo común múltiplo de 28 9
es la multiplicación de 28 por una vez y
cuándo será esto vamos a hacerlo por acá
28 28 por 9 y 19 por 8 72 y llevamos 7 9
por 2 es 18 + 7 es 20 5 252 es el
denominador común entre 28 y 9 por lo
tanto 21 entre 28 lo voy a escribir con
denominador a 252 252 y 6 entre 9
también la voy a escribir con un
denominador de 252 que es el denominador
común ahora lo que quiero que te des
cuenta es que es un denominador muy
y por lo tanto es un poco más tardado o
tal vez un poco más complicado que
simplificar las fracciones sin embargo
creo que vamos bien de aquí para acá lo
que hice fue multiplicar por nueve
entonces 21 no tengo que multiplicar por
nueve por nueve para encontrar el
numerador de esta fracción y cuántos
veintiuno por una vez han déjame hacerlo
por acá 21 por 9 y 19 por 19 9 por 12 18
189 es decir que 21 entre 28 es lo mismo
que 189 entre 252 estas dos fracciones
son exactamente lo mismo
ahora vamos a fijarnos en 6 no menos 9
para llegar a ser 252 lo que hice fue x
28 recuerda que encontré este 252
multiplicando 28 por 9 entonces para
encontrar el numerador de esta fracción
lo que tengo que hacer es multiplicar al
6 por la misma cantidad para que no se
afecte esta fracción entonces lo voy a
multiplicar por 28
cuanto 6 por 28 pues vamos a hacerlo por
acá 28 por 6 6 por 8 48 y llevamos 4 6
por 2 es 12 y 4 son 16 168 entonces aquí
tengo 168 ya está 21 entre 28 es
exactamente lo mismo que 189 entre 252 y
6 entre 9 es exactamente lo mismo que a
168 entre 252 ya tengo un denominador
común y por lo tanto ya puedo comparar
estas dos fracciones voy a comprar la
flexión 189 entre 252 y la fracción 168
entre 252 y si te das cuenta aquí tengo
más partes que aquí aquí tengo 189
partes de estas 252 mientras que aquí
tengo 168 partes de estas 252 por lo
tanto aquí ya estamos viendo que esta
fracción es más grande que esta otra
dicho de otra manera 21 entre 28 es más
grande
692 por la misma lógica y que bueno
digamos la misma respuesta a que éste
era más grande que éste ahora la única
diferencia fue que multiplicamos por
cantidades más grandes
sin embargo tanto simplificar las
fracciones en un primer paso como no
simplificar las nos llevan a la misma
respuesta y ya está esto es todo por
este vídeo